Welcome back everyone this is my new venom
let there be carnage video, they released
a couple new scenes in this also.
This really really hilarious Topher Grace
venom posts that he made recently, trolling
people about Spider-Man No Way Home.
With all the Tobey Maguire stuff coming back
from his movies.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get everything I will be doing
full post credit scene videos Easter egg videos
breakdowns for the entire movie.
Once it comes out later this week.
I also think of allowed to post my review
by Wednesday.
So if I'm able to get that video out fast
enough that I will post a review for the movie
will start with the new footage here.
Then I'll talk about the funny toe for grace
Spider-Man No Way Home venom stuff at the
end of the video, but they start with the
prison break scene of carnage fully for now
emerging from Cletus Kasady there was an earlier
saying that I posted last week that explains
how he gets the carnage symbiote.
So a link that blown the description.
It's a small change from the carnage origin
story in the comics, so in the original Spider-Man
comics Spider-Man, winds up defeating venom
during one of their fights than any brought
get sent to prison and his cellmate, winds
up being Cletus Kasady.
So eventually the venom symbiote comes to
rescue Eddie and when they bust out the venom
symbiote spawns in then that spawn finds Cletus
Kasady in bonds with him becoming carnage
then they break out of prison and go on a
killing spree in Spider-Man has to find out
was going on in the stop them.
Eventually, carnage become so powerful that
Spider-Man in venom have to put their differences
aside team up during the maximum carnage storyline
to take carnage down.
We know there's a big Spider-Man venom crossover
movie this coming up they been hyping up between
Tom Hardy and Tom Holland's Spider-Man seems
logical that they would riff on that kind
of story for their big crossover movie the
difference during venom let there be carnage
is that Cletus winds up biting Eddie in and
just some of his blood and some of the symbiote
than what's that bonds with Cletus Kasady's
body that winds up devolving into a wholly
different symbiote the carnage symbiote.
So is there executing him here.
This scene is meant to be another parallel
for that scene of Eddie Brock inside the medical
scanner where the venom's abusers freaking
out.
Just bursting out of his body.
Only this time for the carnage origin story
they're playing it like a death and rebirth
seem like Cletus Kasady is dying there injecting
him with all these lethal chemicals and you
can see him slowly dying so Cletus dies up
briefly so that he can be reborn as carnage
and there is a big difference in the way the
carnage symbiote bonds with Cletus Kasady
from the way normal symbiote like the venom
symbiote bonds with Eddie Brock or other host
like Flash Thompson agent venom, or even toxin
or anti-venom or the primal symbiote.
Carnage is different because it's not just
a regular symbiote that enters Cletus his
body and forms a partnership with him.
The way that venom in a Brock are partners
or the way Bruce Banner in the whole are partners
also reference the hulk again in a second
to when I talk about the other footage because
a lot of what's going on with venom during
the movie and Eddie Brock is similar to what
was going on between Banner in the whole during
avengers infinity war and Avengers endgame,
but no were not to get Professor venom or
anything like that anytime soon, the difference
with carnage is that the carnage symbiote
and Cletus are bonded at the cellular level
so much that neither one of them Cletus nor
the carnage symbiote knows where one of them
begins and the other one ends they think of
themselves truly as a single being.
Thus the phrase we are carnage that is venom's
catchphrase to he says that all the time we
are venom, but is meant to be totally different.
The way carnage uses that phrase Eddie Brock
and venom agreed to be Brose and work together.
But there still two distinct personalities
to distinct minds Eddie has his own wants
and desires and so does the venom symbiote
carnage is more like a singular mind a single
desire for just complete destruction utter
chaos and that's one of the reasons why he
starts out initially being so much more powerful
than venom because there's no limits with
him.
He just 100% all the time.
Whereas with venom during the movie as Andy
serkis tells it in that clip Eddie and venom
are the odd couple fighting constantly unable
to live together peacefully, but also they
can't stand to be a part in the movie Eddie
is supposed to be just as selfish and self-serving
as comic book Eddie Brock.
Like imagine Spider-Man if you were a total
ass hole and only ever really thought of himself.
Oh wait, you don't have to imagine it because
they actually did that, during the movie,
everyone queue the emo Bully Parker dance
montage.
I cannot wait to see how they handle Tom Holland's
Spider-Man once he gets the symbiote.
I'm not expecting any dance montage or anything,
but don't be surprised, they say that twist
for the venom Spider-Man crossover movie that
all the Sony and Marvel people have been hyping
up recently.
Consequently that crossover is also probably
when the finally give the venom symbiote the
big Spider-Man symbol on his chest from the
comics, but those you that it felt like that's
been missing for the past couple of years
since the first venom movie most of carnage's
powers and abilities are pretty much what
you see from him in the comics, he uses his
symbiote powers to form hard edge weapons
and projectiles if you ever wonder if it's
possible for him to run out of ammo so to
speak like if his weapons are made of himself
extensions of the carnage symbiote itself
and he throws in the people or it venom when
they're fighting does that mean that carnage
loses mass and gets weaker the more he does
that the technical answer to that is yes kind
of the symbiote's can replace their mass not
just carnage venom can do this to any of the
symbiote scan by just consuming more matter
more nutrition eating people eating food usually
though it's the first one eating people symbiote
repair their own tissues the same way the
human body consumes nutrition and converse
that the energy powering your body's ability
to repair it itself is just the symbiote do
that way way faster so carnage were in the
middle of a fight and he needed a reload so
to speak.
All you have to do would be just eating a
couple people symbiote can also make themselves
appear or get even bigger if they want to
as well.
They just need to consume way more matter.
But usually they just depicted as being slightly
larger than the people that there bonded to
more for practical reasons.
Like Eddie Brock is only 59 because Tom Hardy
is 59.
But when the venom symbiote comes out he's
more like seven or 8 feet tall.
It just like Banner in the hulk banner is
average height kind of scrawny the hulk is
about 8 feet tall in his base form but still
built like a tree trunk also talking more
about the hulk references in Avengers infinity
war.
The whole reason the russos explained they
did hulk and banner this way with hulk eventually
refusing to come out is just because he lost
the fight to Thanos it was more about him
hating banner and that was what all the dialogue
about him only wanting hulk for fighting was
meant to be whole basically felt like Banner
was selfish and only used him when it was
convenient for banner and hold had his own
dreams and desires.
Like he wanted to be free.
Just like everyone else.
They had a huge deleted scene during the final
battle and avengers infinity war where they
were going to watch hulk and banner come to
the agreement and for Professor hulk they
said that they opted to say that reveal for
Avengers endgame.
I posted the whole avengers infinity war hulk
deleted scene on my channel a couple years
ago.
So I the Link for that in the description
below.
But in this movie venom and Eddie have their
own version of that kind of a scene where
they have to both come together.
Finally, so they can be even more powerful.
We see some of that in the trailer footage
it takes place in the church year where they
have their big venom versus carnage battle
in these like you need to come out right now.
I will let you eat everybody also this being
a church is a huge Easter egg for a number
of different Spider-Man stories and carnage
stories anytime venom is in a church remind
you, the classic venom origin story.
They did a version of that with the Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man three movie also referencing
Tobey Maguire Spider-Man three.
The toe for grace version of venom recently,
topher grace to read AMA for something completely
unrelated and of course during that.
Someone asked him are you going to be in Spider-Man
No Way Home.
Because of all the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
characters are coming back during that.
Like doctor octopus and the Tobey Maguire
cameo scene that were all expecting of course
and I think were all in agreement that there
is no way the toe for grace is going to show
up during Spider-Man No Way Home.
Like we all just innately understand that
the Naka to bring that character back but
this was toe for grace his way of giving the
funniest troll answer that you've ever heard.
So this is actually toe for grace answering
this kid saying please keep it between us.
But yes I minute the plot starts with Peter
Parker, Tom Holland bone that everyone knows
his identity in then some crazy shit happens
with Dr. strange and doctor octopus Alfred
Molina comes into his dimension.
Then electro in the Green goblin hop out of
one of those energy circles I love the way
he calls it energy circles like he's trying
to be extra funny about it in their like it's
spider stop in time.
Then Tom Hardy and I pop out and battle each
other.
And I when obviously like it's not even a
fight.
I just kick his ass immediately not to give
too much away.
But there also some actors from the original
70s Spider-Man show Aquaman Batman Affleck
not Keaton.
I love the way he could that little detail.
And thanks the Disney Han Solo's goes from
rising Skywalker and that Eve robot from Wall-E
again.
Please keep this between us that is probably
one of the best troll answers that I've ever
seen an actor give about them being questioned
as to whether or not there in a giant movie
with the venom movie is coming out later this
week my post credit scene video will play
post Thursday night or Friday morning and
then I'll do a full breakdown Easter eggs
video make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss any that my full
marvel what if episode eight videos also gonna
post Wednesday to, so there's a lot of big
marvel stuff happening this week everyone
click here for my brand-new marvel a turtles
trailer video all about the celestials and
click here to learn all about the infinity
gauntlet version of Ultron from marvel's what
if.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see the next video!